reminded everybody in Ottawa yesterday
Ottawa Ontario scuse me that I didn't
say [ __ ] there's the first 13 years of
my career I'd still to business no
talking just doing natural way I'm
bombing title is like a visible adapting
with clarity subtle my my name is daddy
stop I've been telling you account
equity i'm tripoli given a pedigree to
mean enough less of my faculty including
the work that I'm doing are the moving
furniture heaven today's episode two
things one the lesson I taught Jordan
which is consistency putting in the work
he's my trainer he taught me how to get
muscles how to tone how to focus and I
taught him how to be a good at Instagram
Saturday morning the weird pro house
that's always poof up I'm Jordan my
trainer
Jordan what uh what did we get focused
on the interim more seriously right at
the beginning of the new year and what
has happened what I tell you doing what
were you doing before before I was
posting once a day maybe oh my god if
that honestly not that five times a week
and then you said post every day three
times a day and I said and I said we
what hashtag hashtag he showed me ideas
hashtag we come today three times a day
engage engage with all my with all
everyone yep yep first day I didn't do
it per se did to answer three I went
crazy success he was like you said I'm
disappointed in you roll over and then
from that day every day three times a
day
hashtag interacting and in less than
eight weeks that have over
3000 new followers and the key is not
even the followers what I've been most
impressed with took a quick peek is just
the engagement level the way they care
about you like just you've built a
community forget about the top-line
amount so people have 10,000 more
followers but only 187 care about them
of your 3 thousands of dollars it feels
like 2,000 care about you yeah that's
amazing
thank you everyone applause you're
welcome
lesson number two very simple my friends
this is a big one for me one of the
things that I'm spending a lot of time
on one that a lot of people aren't
capable of executing which is how much
better life is when you're the bigger
man and woman in every situation no
matter if you're right or wrong no
matter what it is are you capable of
swallowing your pride and having the
humility to to say you're sorry even
when maybe it wasn't yours to say you're
sorry
leadership and Happiness really really
really come at the at the ability to
focus on one move which is can you be
the bigger person the number one thing
that keeps good leaders from becoming
great you know to being great at
something you have to over index you
just have to you have to be able to be
great at it I mean you can be a good
basketball player you can be a great
basketball players a lot of that has to
do with DNA so I think a lot of national
leadership skills you know for me the
reason I aspire to be a great leader is
I truly focus on one variable and I want
everybody to hear this and it's a very
sneaky pillar of my life success which
is when I think about you India or UV
rock or anybody that that I jam with in
my world startup companies that I'm when
I go to Oklahoma City the client I'm
trying to provide 51%
the value I really believe that and that
because I'm this great human being
because I think it's a leverage I think
that if de Raadt feels that I'm slightly
providing more value to him than he's
providing to me financially upside in
the future mentorship whatever it may be
that that's going to make me a great
leader Hey it's how he feels about me
and B it's going to focus me on always
trying to one-up the next person and
when you're a leader one-upping comes in
many forms I'm going to continue to show
you angles that you haven't seen about
yourself
right I'm going to continue to challenge
you financially compensate you give you
opportunity to bring you two things one
upping trying to provide more value to
the other person and I think that uh I
think a lot of great leaders are a lot
of good leaders are 8024 themselves I
think extremely the leaders are 5050 I
think great leaders start to go to the
5149 direction so much of my happiness
and success in relationships and life
are predicated on that singular move
which is always take on responsibility
it's always your fault and it's become a
theme in the last couple of months in
relationships and friendships in
business for a lot of my friends and
contemporaries and I just really wanted
to this little rat rant the short
Saturday episode on that singular move
it is big and so little a little
homework for everybody if you're in the
middle of something right now try to be
the bigger person try to swallow your
pride try to erase the line in the sand
that you
feels like prior try to be
[Music]